[Music]
dragons in dream world's franchise are
powerful reptiles that are found in the
barbaric archipelago and in the Hidden
World which is their place of Origins
they are largely carnivores and eat
other animals with most of them
sufficing on fish and sheep or other
smaller creatures but there are those
species which hunt and even eat other
dragons as well
and so here in this video we will
showcase 10 cannibalistic or Dragon
predators that are seen in the entire
franchise let's get to it number one the
Cav Crasher in dragons race to the edge
it emerges as a formidable animal a
dragon a colossal mystery class Dragon
this wingless Behemoth tries in the
Subterranean world and is armed with a
reinforced beak and Claws it can scale
rock walls even hang upside down from
Stites to navigate its domain this
Dragon bulbus ducks on the back allows
it to excrete a slippery mucus which can
be also set a blaze later on this Dragon
feasts on dragon eggs and dragon
hatchlings mainly of the
fireworms number two the Grim Nasher it
is a Shar class Dragon of moderate size
that made its debut in dragons raised to
the edge it is Crafty and opportunistic
and these dragons adopt a cutting
strategy circling wounded prey for their
advantage despite their pack hunting
nature Grim nashes exhibit a preference
for targeting vulnerable defenseless
dragons rather than engaging with
healthier counterparts what sets them
apart as a perilous force is their
exceptional ability to coordinate to
outsmart their prey number three the
changewing these are medium-sized
mystery class dragons first featured in
The Book of Dragons they are formidable
Predators known for their deadly
abilities these dragons possess unique
skills of changing colors to reflect
their moods and surroundings like
camouflage they also shoot hot corrosive
acid capable of burning through wood and
rocks they are fast agile and Hunt like
a pack of lions with the females doing
most of the hunting praying on smaller
dragons and also wounded larger ones
number four the speed Stingers the Speed
Stinger is a sharp Glass Dragon that
first appeared in Dragons Defenders of
Burke they are the Velociraptors of the
Dragon World they are fast aggressive
and intelligent not to mention they are
the fastest dragons on land they use
coordinated attacks moving imp pcts led
by Elite Speed Stinger its main weapon
is a poisonous Bob tail a sting can
render any human or Dragon completely
paralyzed for hours or even days as such
their pack hunting allows them to take
down larger dragons larger than
themselves number five the scalon the
scarron is a large title class dragon
that was first mentioned in How to Train
Your Dragon it is patient and organized
and it is strategic by Nature scons are
one of the few dragons known to pray on
other dragons they hunt in groups or pts
like killer whales and have picked off
smaller species to near Extinction
instead of fire they scoop up water with
their gullets in their gullets and then
boil it internally and shoot it out
against prey sea Shockers and squiers
are their main
items number six the death grippers the
death gripper is a medium-sized strike
Glass Dragon that first appeared in How
to Train Your Dragon part three the
Hidden World they are a monstrous
species with their protruding Tusk for
claw pincers and poisonous Tails death
grippers can launch thick streams of
potin acid at their targets which is
also flamable and they also have a
poison tip tail which they can used to
hunt and kill other dragons they hunt in
groups like wild dogs and can take down
many other species number seven The
Death Song The Death Song is a large
mystery class dragon that first appeared
in dragons raised to the edge The Death
Song uses a siren like song to leure its
prey making them unresponsive to the
surroundings like a siren sound it
ambushes its sprey striking with an
amber-like secretion that hardens into a
stiff amber-like cocoon this cocoon is
remarkably strong and it is only
penetrable by fire it is also very
powerful physically and therefore has no
problem hunting small and mediumsized
Dragons number eight the Slither wi the
Slither WI a mediumsized mystery class
Dragon introduced in dragons rais to the
edge resembles colossal winged serpents
that often hunt in groups these
creatures swiftly Slither employing a
venomous bite to subdue their prey
before dragging them back to their layer
for consumption known for their
unyielding Pursuit Slither Wings
persistently Chase prey even engaging in
battles with formidable dragons like
death songs showcasing their Relentless
nature and yeah death songs the
formidable predators of other dragons
are also their prey item number nine the
Red Death the Red Death is a gigantic
stoker Claus dragon that first appeared
in the first movie How to Train Your
Dragon it is a gigantic Dragon species
only being surpassed in size by the
Titanic Leviathan the bewilder bees a
red death possess three pairs of eyes
that give it little to no blind spots it
also has large Wings a club tail and a
massive head and a mouth with saltlike
teeth to add to this it can also
hypnotize smaller dragons with an alpha
call and make them all serve it as a
queen bringing it food and if it is
still hungry it will feed on them
instead any smaller dragon can become
its dinner and number 10 the yman gander
also known as the world Serpent and the
midgard serpent this is yet another
serpent-like species it is a large
mystery class dragon that first appeared
in the new series called dragons the
nine Realms it is characterized by its
elongated eike body and distin Frills
that resemble a cobra's hood kind of
like the warbat from the hollow Earth
from the monsterverse the yman gander
holds the top position as a predator
among all dragons and can even be in a
state of dant existence for hundreds of
years without food so that's a pretty
long hibernation time so those are the
10 deadliest predators of dragons in
httyd or How to Train Your Dragon so if
you like this video then check this
other one as well and if you're more
interested in other movie monsters and
creatures then check out our channel so
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam